these women were tied up literally tied
up to the beds and their feet were put
up in forceps
the doctor sat level with the with the
chair at their vagina and they would
control these births now if you can't
really tell a mom that is under
anesthesia directions you can't say push
or do this so they would wait for the
baby to start to come and then they
would go in with forceps
and they would pull these babies out cut
the cord right away whisk the baby away
put him in the nursery right like that's
all the pictures you see back then is
the dad standing smoking their cigars
looking at their babies in the nursery
where the nurses attended to these
babies that was birth that was birth for
a long time the history dates back to
women being on their backs and we know
that squatting is one of the most
universal positions for giving birth
squatting increases the pelvic Outlet by
33 but but the reason that that these
women were placed on their backs is
because they were drugged
and it was convenient for the doctor to
have them level with their feet up and
forceps